there is a an old poem that starts it is
an ill wind that blows no good and I
like to think that Katrina was not until
win
over the 10 15 years prior to Katrina we
had a pretty much the worst public
school system for a city of its size in
the United States if you look at public
education and how its organized you
basically have small monopolies that
enjoy a geographic spread those
monopolies have entered into many unholy
alliances with labor and as a result
it's extremely difficult to change the
equation to change the dynamic and to
change the atmosphere for creativity and
innovation to thrive
well 2003 the state created something
called a recovery school district and it
was designed to address the fact that
some schools were object ly low
achieving schools for very long periods
of time normal state takeovers would
embody a new superintendent coming in
and trying to run the schools just as
the old superintendent did but in this
case we decided to charter the schools
the beauty of the recovery school
district is that by taking over the
schools we took them over into a new
entity the state the recovery school
district in the it did not have a
collective bargaining agreement so it
was a very small effort and it was
pretty much ignored by
the union's at the time that would of
course change later when the larger
takeover took place
so on August 29th you had 126 schools
and the next day you had none and by the
end of that first school year you only
had six schools operating in the city of
New Orleans after the storm I think a
lot of people looked at the whole city
of New Orleans as an opportunity to
reset the table how could we find a
silver lining in this very dark cloud
that was Katrina the governor then
Kathleen Blanco very courageously went
against her base created this takeover
there was an attempt in the legislature
to attach collective bargaining to it if
that was rejected and then we moved
forward and we move forward chartering
schools we got a lot of help from the
outside so that was the strategy now
interestingly after about a year and a
half there was a lot of counter pressure
from the community and it really started
getting messy the experimentation was
scary to people and people were very
very resistant and they started getting
their political strength back again and
started pushing back to the status quo
and that's when I came in and my role in
all of that really was to create an
environment where these third parties
could thrive
now most charters in the country operate
in very toxic environments even if you
have a good charter when you're battling
against the school district and the
school district is trying to outmaneuver
you and they are much bigger and much
more agile in being able to do that it's
hard for charters to survive but here in
New Orleans charters are the dominant
player on the landscape and we tried to
create a protective environment not
because their charters but because there
are schools and we've tried to give them
an even opportunity to operate and I
think when you do that I think charters
will prevail for the obvious reason that
they create an environment where
innovation and creativity thrive far
more than half in fact almost
three-quarters of the schools in the
city of New Orleans come next year will
be charter schools and over the long
haul
we hope all will be charged schools a
traditional school system has a school
board a superintendent superintendent
has a big staff the staff oversees
principals tells them what to do when to
do it how to do it what we've tried to
do in New Orleans is create a management
structure that oversees schools in a
fundamentally different way instead of
managing how they run their school
building we try to create a climate
where they can run their school building
and where they have control the
principals have control over the
finances they have control over the
human capital and they have control over
the academic agenda and then what we say
to them is you need to meet a level of
performance we've seen anywhere from
two-thirds to three-quarters of our
school Excel at rates of growth that far
outstrip other schools on average in the
state of Louisiana
but you do see some schools which don't
do well so now we have something called
a transformational school process where
each year we target four of the lowest
achieving schools regardless of whether
they're a charter or a traditional
school and we say we're gonna take you
out of business
prior to the storm very few people in
the city of New Orleans who sent their
children to public schools had any
interest in charter schools after the
storm and early on when charter schools
were just developing there was a
tremendous amount of resistance because
of philosophical beliefs but now that
people have seen success in charter
schools while they may not understand
them and while they may be told that
they're bad they want to send their kids
to charter schools I wouldn't say that
charter schools are the answer
I would say they can be an answer and
more likely to be an answer in the right
environment but traditional schools can
be as well if the district office gives
the kind of autonomy to a traditional
school the Legislature passed a bill to
allow for what amounts to a voucher we
call it a scholarship where children who
are going to the lowest achieving
schools in our city in the recovery
school district are able to take dollars
and go purchase and education at a
private or parochial school as we gain
more success the opposition grows more
vigorous you know they're they're
starting a major ad campaign here in
Louisiana to try and
some of these reforms the School Board
Association is doing the same thing so
those two enterprises are probably oddly
enough in partnership working with each
other management and labor are teaming
up to try and beat this back so the
outcome is still in doubt but I am
reasonably optimistic